uh for joining me today
uh we were joking earlier now I've been
really joking
when you need something done call in the
military
and we'll get FEMA we'll make sure it
gets done
uh look
we're about to get a covid-19 briefing
from military Medical Teams on the
ground in Arizona Michigan and New York
they're part of a major deployment of
our nation's armed forces to help
hospitals across the country manage this
surge of the Omicron virus as a surge
does have an impact on hospitals like
all health care workers they are heroes
and I'm grateful for what they do
but before we begin I want to provide an
update on our fight against covid-19 and
announce new steps
first the update I know we're all
frustrated as we enter this New Year
Omicron variant is causing millions of
cases and record hospitalizations
I've been I've been saying that as we
remain in this pandemic this is a
pandemic of the unvaccinated
and I mean by this right now both
vaccinated and unvaccinated people are
testing positive
but what happens after that could not be
more different
if vaccinated people test positive
they're overwhelmingly have either no
symptoms at all or they have mild
symptoms and if they're if you're
unvaccinated if they test positive there
are you are seven teams times more
likely to get hospitalized as a result
they're crowding our hospitals leaving
little room for anyone else who might
have a heart attack or an injury in an
automobile accident or any injury at all
and yes the unvaccinated or dying from
covet 19.
but here's the deal because we fully
vaccinated nearly 210 million Americans
the majority of the country is safe from
severe covid-19 consequences
that's why even as the number of cases
among the vaccinated Americans go up
deaths are down dramatically from last
winter
for example before this vaccination
requirement the United States should be
United Airlines
was was averaging one employee dying a
week from cover 19.
after implementing its requirement it's
led to 99 percent of its employees being
vaccinated United had 3 600 employees
test positive but zero hospitalizations
zero deaths in over eight weeks
but as long as we have tens of millions
of people who will not get vaccinated
we're going to have full hospitals and
needless deaths so the single most
important thing to determine your
outcome in this pandemic is getting
vaccinated
if you're not vaccinated join the nearly
210 million American people who are
vaccinated if you are vaccinated join
the nearly 80 million Americans who have
gotten the booster shot
with the strongest protection possible
vaccines are safe they're free and
they're widely available so do it today
please for your sake the sake of your
kids the sake of the country
now I don't like to uh
you know
outline the next steps were taken
against I'd like to outline the next
steps we're taking against over on the
the Omicron variant vaccinations are
obviously the most important thing we're
doing
but they're but they are not the only
important thing first masking masking
masking is an important tool to control
the spread of covet 19. and when you're
indoors in public places you should wear
the mask
and you're they're a lot you know lots
of different kinds of masks out there in
the system in the Center for Disease
Control and prevention the CDC says that
wearing a well-fitting mask
of of any of them is certainly better
than not wearing a mask if it's well
fitting but over your nose
and but it's about one-third about
one-third of Americans report they don't
wear a mask at all
as I've said in the last two years
please wear a mask
if you're in a you know I I think it's
part of your patriotic Duty it's not
that comfortable
it's a pain in the neck but
I've taken every action I can as
president to require people to wear
masks in federal buildings and on
airplanes and trains Because the
Internet they cross state lines
I made sure that our doctors and nurses
and First Responders have the mask they
need
never again we're going to have our
nurses using homemade masks and garbage
bags over their clothing for hospital
because they don't have the gowns
we've more than tripled our stockpile of
the most protective specialized n95 mask
since coming into office
this is going to make sure that there
will be an ample supply of health care
workers and First Responders
we also have helped make sure that high
quality masks are widely available and
ample Supply at affordable prices sold
online and in stores
but I know that for some Americans the
mask is not always affordable or
convenient to get so next week we'll
announce we'll announce how we are
making high quality masks available to
American people the American people for
free
I you know I know we all wish that we
could finally be done with wearing masks
I get it
but there is a they're a really
important tool to stop the spread
especially of a highly transmittable
homocron variant so please please wear
the mask
second testing we're seeing real
Improvement in testing
when I got here we were doing fewer than
2 million tests a day
now
and it's changed none of these tests
were at home or rapid tests
this month it's estimated that we will
hit approximately 15 million tests a day
and we'll have over 375 million at home
rapid tests in January alone
that's a huge leap we've taken a number
of steps including invoking the defense
production act as early as last February
to ramp up production
you know and we're on track we're on
track to roll out a website next week
where you can order free tests shipped
to your home
and in addition to the 500 million half
a billion tests that are in the process
of being acquired to ship to you homes
for free today I'm directing my team to
procure an additional half a bill
additional 500 million more tests to
distribute for free
I mean a billion tests in total
to meet future demand
and we'll continue to work with the
retailers and online route and on online
retailers
to increase availability
and for those who want an immediate test
we continue to add FEMA testing sites so
that there are more than more free
in-person testing sites for those of you
with insurance you can get reimbursed
for eight tests a month
for those without insurance we have over
20
000 free testing sites all around the
country
you can find the nearest testing sites
for you by Googling covid test near me
Google covid test near me
and to help lead our federal testing
program
I've talked I've I've
seen me I've tapped Dr Tom I hope I
pronounced angel
inglesby correct is that right Jeff
uh and uh he's one of the world's
leading infectious disease experts and
I'm grateful for his willingness to help
tackle this challenge
third thing
today we'll discuss our Hospital
response efforts
just thanks and this thanks just since
Thanksgiving over 800 military and other
federal emergency Personnel have been
deployed to 24 States tribes and
territories including over 350 military
doctors nurses and Medics helping staff
the hospitals are in short supply
this is on top of more than 14 000
National Guard members that are active
activated in 49 states
these deployments in my direction and
thanks to the American Rescue plan are
fully paid for by the federal government
we've shipped over 5.5 million pieces of
personal protective equipment gloves
gowns masks to protect Frontline
healthcare workers we're shipping more
treatments of covid-19 which includes
antiviral pills that at any point during
this pandemic in addition I've directed
FEMA to work with every state territory
in the District of Columbia to make sure
they have enough hospital bed capacity
today I'm announcing our next deployment
of six additional Federal Medical Teams
a total of more than 120 military
medical personnel to Six hard-hit States
Michigan New York
New Jersey Ohio Rhode Island
and let me close with this it's been a
long road
but what's clear as we get through this
when everybody does their part
no matter where you live
no matter your political party we've got
to fight this together
unfortunately while our military is
stepping up as they always do
there are others sitting on the
sidelines and we're standing in the way
if you haven't gotten vaccinated do it
personal choice
impacts us all our hospitals our
countries
I make a special appeal to social media
companies and media Outlets please deal
with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your shows
it has to stop
covid-19 is one of the most formidable
enemies America has ever faced
we've got to work together not against
each other
we're America
we can do this
so the military medical teams in the
ground thank you for all and everything
you're doing
and I'll stop here so we can get to the
briefing started
thank you for taking the time
to restrict their activities given to
your health officials say most Americans
will get coveted at some point folks
we'll talk about that later come on
trust your Administration has been
reported when the farmers assistant
start voting right do you think the
Republicans
appreciate you thank you so much
thank you so much thank you how much
longer do you think the school people
have to wear masks
me too
we'll start in one minute
all right Mr President we'll start with
administrator Chris swell whose team at
FEMA as you know has been on the front
lines of the coveted response over to
you administrator and everything else
Mr President thank you Jeff uh Mr
President as you know FEMA has been
working in the covid mission since day
one our objective has always remained
the same to protect and save as many
lives as possible
during every disaster FEMA strength is
our ability to coordinate with